and then a couple from elizabeth
first do you worry that florida will go
downhill now that so many liberals are
fleeing there do you think they fully
understand why they had to run in the
first place
and when florida texas arizona and
tennessee become overpopulated what
state will be the next promised land
so i do worry and one of the reasons
that i went back and forth a lot between
thank you for that question i go back
and forth a lot
i still go back and forth a lot we're
here now i'm in florida for the next
couple of years that's commitment but in
my mind
i was always like well desantis is there
now desantis is kind of running the show
without a desantis what does florida
look like i don't know
i don't know i always felt like in texas
texas is rooted in
these freedoms this two-way stuff it's
root like think about a tree's roots if
you try to like rip something out of the
ground and those roots are really in
there you're gonna have a really hard
time you're going to be tugging and
tugging and i did that as a kid sadly i
would tug and talk but those roots were
like you're not getting me out that's
how i think of texas with a lot of these
issues because it's a long time of like
freedoms and personal responsibility and
they do like a lot of stuff related to
homeschooling there it's kind of the
homeschool capital of the country in
many ways
and
florida is kind of finding that it's
finding itself in that area still and i
think desantis was a big part of that so
i do worry
i do worry but i'll tell you this
and i told this to pbd when i came out
here i said i don't know if it's going
to be florida for me long term i need to
see where it lands
but i will tell you i am going because i
have a child he comes first we will be
in a place where those roots feel stable
to me no matter where that is and if
that means one day i pick up the show
which i'm gonna have this show's gonna
grow i'm gonna grow with you guys you're
gonna grow with me i'm going to grow on
you even if you hate me you're going to
be like jed's like a a growth i can't
get rid of i just can't and i like
having her there that's how you're going
to feel
but we will be somewhere where those
values are built in because that's
really important to me and i don't know
where they go after
texas for texas is getting real
populated austin area is becoming you
know
people there now colorado as well though
um nashville tennessee is blowing up
um
that's why jeremy's like let's go to
wyoming
i said jeremy when we were picking
places to live i was like well i don't
know if it's going to be dallas or
nashville or south florida and he was
like
can i throw montana on the map he really
was like he wanted
let's get away from out of these cities
away from people like let's just go
where
you know he was jeremy was like the
scene in what's that movie the patriot
where he rides with the flag out he's on
the horse and he's got the flat that was
my husband he was like let freedom ring
that's where i'm going so he wanted
security in that and i don't know i
don't know i don't know where it's going
to trickle out but um i do think there's
enough people now in the country
that are like
okay i'm done giving there's a guy jesse
kelly
shout out to jesse
who when i first started listening to
him no joke
um seeing him on twitter that is i was
like
he's too much he was like the communists
these communists everything was the
communists i was like this guy's too
much
and i was like more of a let's all just
sit and talk this out you know this is
really good i'm gonna go on the view
change hearts and minds
you know and then i realized okay my
strategy gets me cut off midway they cut
your mic they label you misinformation
they try to disgrace you and they try to
wreck your entire book and his way
actually calls people what they are
so i i i'm much more inclined to embrace
it now and it's funny i think there's a
lot of people like that that were like i
played nice for a really long time but i
realize when i play nice you step on me
like an ant and i'm not gonna have that
so now i'm gonna be a red ant and i'm
gonna bite
that's how i feel if you like the short
clip you can catch another one here or
you can catch the full episode right
here
you